each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so when i come again to this lactation
about data-driven environmental science
and our first speakers comes from ncsa
at the illinois in chicago and is going
to talk to us about opportunities for
integration of multimodal data and data
for the water sciences community
the batsman as to share just interviews
the title of this presentation is about
opportunities for integration
multi-model and data for the water
science community and this is
co-authored by a big year who was a
postdoc when he worked at and say say
and now is on the faculty member at
Rutgers University and the Barbara means
who is a professor at both ends essay
and department of civil and the
environment engineer and I worked at
NCSA cyber environment and Technology
Group and since this session is is about
the data driven environment science and
we already ncsa already has several
technical talks about technology
included to pro this morning and
streaming data technology yesterday so
my purpose of this talk is trying to
give a perspective from the data driven
environment science perspective how we
actually how technology actually enable
things that which were harder to do not
easily to do and and I try to I try to
explain many challenges and and and and
particularly the use case that we are
targeted on so this is the outline of my
talk so in the introduction part that
will basically described the term of
models because I realized when we talk
about the models what that's basically
everybody means different things so I
want to just pinpoint what exactly what
I mean here and then a particular to
particular problems of interest I want
to highlight in this target why is the
data resolution gap so how we actually
enable a multi-model data integration
and transform
at runtime and the other wise injecting
a reservation data for real ha model
calibration so this two problem specific
problems motivated by our use case which
we I will highlight later and I also try
to put this into perspective for from
the community perspective and try to
highlight the community chance on
integrating multi models and and
specifically because I have been
involved with two initiatives one is
called a CSV ms community service
standard mutterings system and then the
other one is the cahsee a mothering
framework a platform so i will talk
about a little bit on that and then use
case is basically a specific case on the
name of real-time data driven
application and system and a particular
we are talking about the stormwater
management case and i talked about some
challenges our resolves into some
discussion and finally the conclusions
so in this talk i basically classify the
models into two broad categories why is
the data driven models and usually it's
some statistical machine learning
methods that trying to calculate some
kind of meaningful statists hero trying
to feel the data are trying to learn
something from the data or maybe just
simple filtering and the transformation
doing some interpolation or
extrapolation and those are all domain
specific models but it is purely just
stayed hard driven and doesn't involve
any physics with it but in on the other
hand there are a bunch of physics based
models which have been developed in many
communities and in the Environmental
Committee that's the same thing so while
people are talking about the data driven
environment science I think it's
important to not forget about the
physics face the models although those
this to our
be interrelated so I I can give some
examples later so the this kind of
physical space model basically described
physics-based the differential equations
for key physical processes and for
example hydrology and high dollar
hydraulics models and this two kinds of
models can be used in a mixed and
matched way and so so you could have
multiple hybrid data-driven models to
process observe a shindig huh or any
particular input data and for example
you could use all kinds of machine
learning tools for peak flood
forecasting without invoking any
particular physical space to model any
particular hydrologic models but the
second case would be that you could have
multiple of physical base models and you
plan for the same kind of scenario but
then at the end you would use particular
data driven model are several data
driven models to select based on the the
fitness of the physics models the input
and output and trying to see based on
that criteria to select the particular
hydrologic models and then lastly you
could have multiple data driven models
first run against with some kind of
observation models and then you ran some
physical space the model to basically
better date or fuse them to correct bias
so that you get better results so those
are those are all the generic scenarios
you would encounter in today's data
driven environmental science and in
particular I mean there are some many
problems with how we can enable that
kind of multi model integration but in
particular I want to talk about two
specific problems
first wise we call the data resolution
gap problem so so you have multiple data
integration you want to integrate
whether it's data driven or physics
driven you you read the data exchange at
the specific spatial location of ham
steps in different models have different
spatial temporal resolutions and for for
temporal dependency sometimes you could
have a sequential or loop based the
relationship among models so so those
those are basically the the biggest
challenge even before we can actually
start to say we do a lot of science
driven decision making or anything like
that so so I will I would give you a
specific use case and later to
illustrate the point and the second one
is injecting a reservation data for
real-time model calibration and this is
very typical in dynamic data driven
application in the system or adaptive
control of the environment system where
you want to run some model to predict
what you need to act but then at the
beginning of your prediction model ran
you have you don't have the real data
but why the the action is progressing
you need to reiterate how to parry rate
both your input and your actions so
there's a feedback loops there that we
need to act upon so that you are not
just running models in the pure cyber
world without taking into account what's
actually happening in the physical world
so that that's that's one the other
major challenge so I'll highlight a to a
specific water science community chance
there are many other smaller ones but
this true I happen to know so I just
highlight here so the first line is the
community service dynamic modeling
system
so they are doing integration of
simplified open my which urban meyer i
will introduce just next slide and and
do is common component architecture and
i have been on their cyber informatics
in the numerix working group for almost
a year and just trying to learn what
they are doing and so so this is a i
think it's a huge initiative and
investment from NSF for a single
sub-community in the in the in the
environment area and then the other one
is more broad aware well known is the
quasi consortium of universities for the
advancement of hydrologic science
community hydrologic modeling platform
so that's basically a initiative that
which creates a blueprint for community
hydrological modeling platform foot and
trying to do things and realize that
dream for the neck in the next five
years and they are currently considering
an earth system modern form framework
and ola mi and these are two major
initiatives auto from my observation
right now mostly they are considering
just physical space model kind of
integration but i will highlight that
that's probably a not enough for our use
case so in general why why is it often
difficult to link models of course it's
written in different programming
languages and and but then the biggest
thing i see right now when we actually
start working on this kind of projects
is the data resolution gap so so for
example the physical space model usually
have different different
dimensionalities and they may use
different types of computational Greer's
rectangles triangles polygons and then
each model may have their own hand rube
o'clock so if you want to integrate then
and that's that's the first gap you want
to solve and for physical based models
cstm s actually are summarizing in three
common types of covering issues first
lines you have a vertical stack of
Greece which may present a different
domains different subdivision of the
main or different process in the
environment and you want layer them
together and in between layer you want
to communicate the data and then the
second type is nested usually you have a
high resolution model embedded in a
lower resolution or more larger scale
model and it's sort of like adaptive
mesh refinement but they are in
different models and then third one is
sort of like a boundary condition kind
of coupling you happen to have different
models use the same boundary better than
modern different kind of process so you
have to share that data transfer between
that boundary so this is a picture from
sis TMS strategy plan and basically you
can see it set a data integration you
modeling but it basically says that you
have some so many models described so
many processes and you want to you want
to integrate a boundary at the
initialization part at the the parameter
part and of course you want to present a
global view of the abbot results and
that's that's basically the the big
chance that people want to do and of
course it's not realized that is not
realized yet and then a open mi which is
another
standard or interface standard that came
from Europe and they have been spending
lots of efforts on defining how water
models in particular physics based model
because they tested that what they are
considering but they are not considering
specifically like the use case i will
present later so but in general what
they they are doing is basically trying
to cheat model as linkable component but
since not a model not all models are
created equally as component so you have
to wrap it and then obey mi provides
that kind of interface and the basic
mechanics and they use to to integrate
data is basically requesting with high
so the visor you send every passing and
you wait and hope you get a reply and
and the current version is 1.4 and they
said later on they will offer a loop
mechanism the basic command is basically
just get values and you can implement
that interface in in any programming
language you want so the extended data
are described by quantity time
description or location which is
basically what i call the
spatial-temporal somatic information but
since this is a request in reply and
specifically for linking physical base
models it's not a necessary especially
for our real-time case it's not a
necessary useful at this moment all the
way I mean I'm in the process to learn
how that may be to use but as I said
even the CSD ms community they are
basically simplified this and try to
integrate it with you and use the do ye
CCA framework so back to what we are
doing right now so that our use case
basically is
real harm stormwater management system
in Chicago and by the way this kind of
storm water management system is very
common in many urban areas the urban
cities in us all of the word I mean in
US alone there are several hundred
cities suffer this kind of deficiency in
managing stormwater so what exactly are
the difficulties here so so as you can
see in a normal dry weather system you
will have a combined sewer system just
transport a sewer from your residence
your business district and it will be
discharged into the wastewater plant to
them in the prom but then when the when
the storm comes this same system we are
transport does the rain for that the
storm water and then when the capacity
is exceeded then there's no there's no
way to pump it to the wastewater
treatment plant and then they have just
discharged for the river which cause
pollution and many other health issues
so in Chicago in particular there are
multi-billion dollars construction
project to construct the underground
tunnels and the tanks try to store the
storm water in case they can alleviate
this kind of problem but even after they
spend billions dollar or in the progress
to spend in that this I mean the sphere
a major challenge although they have
improved a lot but they still want to
know when I can actually transfer
redirected the combined sewer to another
pipe or another tank when I can actually
close open the gate to release the water
to minimize the impact so so this is a
to illustrate the the actual complexity
here I want to show you the animation
where is the emanation
too close
oh it's just pay okay
right so as you see on the right side
there's the lake michigan leg and all
those network lines is basically the
chicago shoes searched and then the
moving clouds as you can say is just a
rain and rain in progress and all the
red does is basically the CSO discharge
so as you can see this is a this is this
this happens very fast i mean in terms
of hours you would have this is a i
think the animation itself is about 12
hours period but basically when you
actually when you actually see the rain
front terms you have to write if you
want to predict how you would act upon
this kind of spatio-temporal ran for
fees on your engineer system and you
have to run models and then you have to
adjust what it actually happened in the
physical world and then to prevent all
those dots happening so so this is a
very complex natural engineered cobbled
system because the natural party is the
is the weather and rm4 feed about that
but the engineer system the sewer
Network and other things are basically a
meh mate so so in order to our tackle
this problem the first to challenge we
and encounter is data resolution gap so
the real-time hydrology hydraulics
madhuri needs real hammer info data a
spatial temporal resolution that are not
readily available anywhere and so we
need we have to give up data driven
models to chance for real time raw
NEXRAD data into ram for data and
reproduce and republish as new virtual
ram for sensors with prominence
as we implement in our workflow system
so that so we we can actually do spatial
interpolation temporal aggregation and
somatic transformation change it rate of
refractory to rm48 so as you can see
that this big clouds then you can you
can do arbitrary polygon based ram for
estimation and then you get a new
real-time virtual ram for sensors and
then when we talk about the virtual
sensor we we are not just talking about
the new time series data screen because
it's not just numbers of 0.2 2
millimeter rainfall we have to also
manage all those derived metadata
including the spatial location or the
other polygon areas the temporal
frequency the somatic interest and other
GIS layers and that's very very useful
for actually the model the output
actually can be unifying man you'd with
other raw sensor data as well as model
Adam any other model stuff so the so the
result is we we actually can do any real
time any point real time based put a rim
for data so this this was a big cloud
here and you can see you can you can see
at the red point on the map is basically
a virtual sensor and then autos green
white points are USGS cages but then you
act we actually can can see the model
may require a point that are not
available in other locations so we
actually can visualize that okay this is
the real you engage those at a virtual
rain gauge and you can tell from the
province record and then you can
reference details in our paper and then
the other party is the polygon
guys are more complicated because this
is the this is the basically the sewer
shed which is basically each polygon is
a distraction you need so the water the
some water we have float one out out for
in that polygon so by doing polygon
pastry at hand rim for data we can
visualize and quantify the rainfall
intensity in the whole sewer shed and
identifying which one which area is the
weakest part and consequently listen I
mean minimum mean this already gives us
the opportunity to to improve our
situation awareness and understand which
party is the weakest link and this is
also has a publication on ACMG is once
we have that kind of data next step is
to do data-driven real-time model
predict control so as I said that there
are in the past when we run our models
everything is happening in the computer
world we use computer generated data and
then run a motto and then have the
output and you just run once and you say
okay this is this is what it should be
done but when you actually do a
real-time model predict control this is
not enough so what what what's the
challenge the challenge is that we want
to inject in a reservation data for
real-time collaboration so at at the
beginning of your your model run you
want at usually like if you want to
predict the next two hours how you're
going to react on the unfolding storm
you want to say i need the ram for data
two hours ahead in order to even run
this model to predict what i should act
upon but that that's a luxury a
requirement of course we can we can use
some now past
data from Noah but is a prediction is
not a review observationally de once you
starting run in this model you will see
that your predict the rainfall does not
match the observer ran for which comes
continuously from our virtual sensor and
you want to uh and you are you also want
to see like whether the control action
happen in reality matched what you
predict that you have to do but you
didn't do that or you did it in other
ways so there's a there's a feedback
loop that you want to recalibrate and
refuse your infuse your observation data
into your input data so that you can
rerun and restart your your model for
the next prediction stage so that's
that's the major challenge and and we
are actually working on this hopefully
have some some more results in the
future and some some I'll just quickly
offer some some summarization and
discussions so we try to exploit
externalize the spatio-temporal somatic
metadata management for the model the
data so as I pointed out that for both
physical base tomorrow or data driven
model we want to manage those spatial
temporal semantical information and as
well as well as other metadata house so
for example the universe ends when one
we actually visualize it you won't know
which GIS layer they are located and
then we feel like at this moment the
ogen mi is not sophisticated enough for
us to use for for real-time
collaboration and coupling and we are
working on the adaptive workflow
capability so in summary in conclusion
so the multi model integration are
important for their driven environment
in water signs and our use case
basically opposed to major challenge
wins the data resolution gap a real-time
feedback calibration injecting data in
tomorrow at the random and we have made
big progress on solving the problems and
our own valiant effort effort we are
benefiting many other dynamic data
driven multi-model application in the
system so of course or any interest song
collaboration will be welcomed and I
finally I would acknowledge my funding
support other and the team in NCAA which
is the seven right and technology group
thank you